Today we're going to show you how to
correct your posture within minutes. So
you can go from this, okay, to this
right here. As you sit on your computer
and hours go by, you're going to find
yourself all of a sudden slouch forward.
What's really wild about bad posture is
that for every inch that your head goes
forward this way off this neutral plane,
you're adding 10 pounds of weight on the
upper back and neck area. And so many
people have this issue. They go get the
muscles worked on. They get an
adjustment, but they don't fix the
underlying cause, which we're going to
get into today. After the exercise I'm
going to show you today, you're going to
be really surprised how your neck is
going to feel really loose and your
muscles on your upper back are just
going to kind of really loosen up. I
think you're going to be surprised how
much of that tension is connected just
to your posture. So stay with me because
once you hear and understand what I'm
going to talk about, like you're never
going to have this problem again. Number
one, your real problem is not that
posture. It's not because of laziness.
It's because of one thing called fashca.
What is fascia? Fashcia is a connective
tissue that surrounds everything. It
literally molds your entire body into
whatever shape it is right now. And what
it does is it adapts to whatever
position you are in most of the time.
And for most people, they're sitting
behind a computer probably like you are
right now. But today, we're going to
show you how to undo it just a couple
minutes every single night. So, in this
first exercise that I'm going to show
you, I'm going to use the bands, but you
can easily just use a broomstick or a
pole. So, this is what you're going to
do. You're going to actually take the
band and you're going to put this band
in back of [clears throat] your head and
pull it back like your shoulders back
like this. And then you're going to
slowly tilt to your right side. Okay?
All the way to the right side. We're
taking the fascia and we're stretching
it and we're making it into a different
shape. Okay? And then we're going to
take it on the left side and do the same
thing on this side right here. So if you
have a broomstick or some type of stick
or something like this, okay, we're just
doing a lateral bending to the right, a
lateral bending to the left,
and you're just going to do 10 times
each side as the first exercise. This is
going to really open your ribs and the
fascia on the front part of your chest
that seems to be the culprit that's
pulling you forward down like this. All
right, now let's get to the second
fashcia exercise. We'll do the same
thing we did before. So, we're going to
hold the band like this, but this time
you're going to twist to the left and
then you're going to laterally flex
down. Okay? Just like this. Then you're
going to twist to the right and
laterally flex down. And you're simply
going to do that 10 times each side. So
what you're really doing is you're
taking all the slack out of this wet
suit that you have, this connective
faucious suit. We're taking all the
tension out of it and we're just making
it a little bit bigger. We're creating
more space in the areas that are
restricted. But then the next day when
you wake up, you'll be sitting there and
like why am I completely sitting in a
neutral position? I have no need to
slouch. With this exercise, you might
need to get one of these weighted clubs.
They come in like 10 pounds, 20 pounds,
15 pounds, 5 lbs. And I have them
different weights. And you're going to
be using this to add a little more
tension when you do this stretch. You
have your legs spread out and you're
holding this club above your head going
side to side as you're maintaining your
shoulder posture over your hips. Going
to the right, going to the left. Also
looking up to the opposite side when you
do that. But this really elongates the a
muscle called the latisimus dorsy and
opens up your rib cage and the muscles
around your shoulders. So do 10 times
each side. So that would be a total of
20 left to right, left to right. In this
next exercise is called the bow string
stretch. What you're going to do is take
one leg, cross it over the other foot,
and you're going to stretch in the
opposite direction with your arm over
your head. And then you're going to
switch legs and do the opposite
direction. Stretch over as far as you
can, but you're going to repeat this
back and forth. So you're stretching all
the fascia on one side of your body,
including through the hips, underneath
your arm, and even through the rib cage
on the side. So it really gives you a
lot more space and elasticity on the
left and right lateral parts of your
body. Okay, this next exercise is one of
my favorites. It's just basically a dead
hang. You need a pull-up bar or you need
some rings that you can hold on. But
you're basically using your whole body
weight to create a tractioning effect of
all the fashcia in your upper body,
including around your scapula and your
shoulders, underneath your shoulders and
your neck. It's an amazing stretch for
fashca, especially for your midback, but
I would recommend doing it at least 30
seconds to a minute once a day. And this
last one is an amazing stretch for your
fashca. You're going to be kneeling down
with both hands behind your upper
buttocks and you're going to be arching
backwards looking up. Okay? As you do
this, with this exercise, you're
stretching all of the anterior or front
part of your fashcia on your thighs,
through the front part of your hips,
through your abdomen, through your upper
chest. So, you're reversing this entire
forward posture to an amazing stretch
where it's going to really pull you out
of this posture. And you just need to do
this like 10 repetitions, okay? And it
creates a huge effect on your posture.
When the front part of your body is like
a rubber band, no matter what you do,
it's just going to constantly pull you
forward. But once you do these
exercises, you're going to be able to
just sit there comfortably and not have
to use effort to sit up tall. Now,
before you click away, do this one thing
right now. I put something together
called my personal daily routine. The
one that actually makes me feel like I'm
18 years old despite being 60 years old.
And I put this all in one printable
page. It's a checklist. And it's 100%
free. And you can click it in the
download in the description, print it
out, put it on your refrigerator, and
follow it every single day. And the last
thing I want to mention is I have
another awesome video on posture with
different exercises. And if you haven't
seen this one, you got to check it out.
I put it up right here. Click it. Watch
it.